hi I'm Brian and this video I'll be
talking about Pais India Python package
for the sparse identification of
nonlinear dynamical systems we've got
our code is up on github and there's a
documentation site as well I'll show
these links again at the end of the
video so today I'll be talking to you
about first of all what the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamical
systems or Sindhi algorithm is I'll talk
about how you can use paisa neat to back
out
governing dynamical systems from
measurement data I'll go a little I'll
talk a little bit about the structure of
PI Cindy and then I'll briefly give an
overview of some of the more advanced
features of pi cindy so start with the
motivating example let's say I have
conducted an experiment where I took a
particle placed at some point in space
and then watched it evolve in time
taking measurements every 0.01 seconds
for say 10 seconds I then want to try to
come up with a model that allows me to
predict the behavior of the particles
starting at other points in space so the
first thing I'll do is just plot some
measurement data that someone gives me
so the particle starts out down there
and then over time it oscillates upward
in this way so one method I could do I
could use to try to come up with
governing equations is the cindy method
this gives me a way to translate the
measurement data into a plausible
dynamical system governing the time
evolution of the of the system so what
what it tries to do is take the
measurement data X and then find a
function f that governs how its
derivative behaves so the key
observation
behind Cindy is that often each of the
component functions of F so the
derivatives of each of the different
measurement variables tend to be sparse
in the space of possible functions so
for example if we write down this fi and
we write it as a linear combination of
some basis functions in men if we pick
those bases
functions in a smart way then most of
these coefficients will end up being
zero so Cindy tries to use sparse
regression to find these coefficients
what the algorithm looks like in a
little more detail is first we're going
to take our data and stack it into this
big data matrix X where each column
corresponds to a different measurement
variable and each row corresponds to a
different point in time we'll also form
a derivative matrix X dot which is just
the time derivatives of all these points
if you aren't able to form that for
measurement based directly on
measurement data then you can often
infer it by differentiating the
measurement data so pison you'll be able
to do that automatically the next thing
we'll do is pick a set of basis
functions to form our library matrix
capital theta so as an example one of
these function based functions might be
polynomials of degree two and so what
that sub matrix would look like would
just be all the different quadratic
combinations of the measurement
variables and these vector products and
powers are understood to be carried out
element wise so the final thing we need
to do is find a set of sparse
coefficient vectors that satisfies this
approximation problem or that
approximately solves this problem so the
eighth column of this matrix corresponds
to the coefficients for the eighth
coordinate function of F or the eighth
variable F measurement variable this
plot here just shows an overview of what
the Sindhi method looks like for if it
were applied to the Lorenz
equation so we measure the state from
the Lorenz system we then obtain a
derivative matrix and we try to to fit
this these library functions in this
case the library consists of polynomials
of degree up to five we try to find
sparse linear combination of them that
recreates the dynamics so that sparse
matrix is identifying the active terms
from the library and hopefully what we
get out at the end of the day is
something that looks similar to
the original model that would that
generated the data in the first place so
how does this connect to PI Cindy well
hi Cindy basically has one sub module
dedicated to each of the three terms in
the approximation problem we saw before
so PI Sania differentiate is going to
help us form this this derivative matrix
X dot pi stand-up feature library is
going to help us form this library
matrix theta and then PI Synod
optimizers provide sparse regression
techniques for computing sy the core
object in PI Cindy is the Cindy class
and thus ending class has three major
attributes that also reflect the three
different terms in this approximation
problem so it's got a differentiation
method a feature library and an
optimizer corresponding to each of these
three sub mod objects in each of these
three sub modules so what does it look
like to actually apply pi cindy to the
data so let's go ahead and import pi
Cindy and then form a cindy model with
all the default attributes what does
that look like if we print it out it's a
little bit hard to parse but basically
it's got a differentiation method which
in this case is a finite difference
method it's got a feature library
consisting of polynomial features of
degree up to two and it's got an
optimizer which in this case is the
sequentially thresholded least squares
algorithm which was the method proposed
in the original cindy paper for solving
the approximation problem so how do we
actually fit it to the data well first
we're going to quickly just form a t
vector corresponding to all the points
in time where we took our measurements
and then we're just going to apply model
dot fit to the data and the time the
time points printing out that model we
get something that looks like this so
the differential equation for the first
coordinate or the first measurement
variable is kind of complicated the
second one is relatively simple let's
see how well it fits the data to do that
we can one way to do that is to use the
simulate function which allows us to
simulate this discovered model forward
in time from some different initial
condition in this case we'll just pass
in the same initial condition as the
orig
data and then just see how this new
model stacks up so it does a pretty it
does qualitatively decent job of
mimicking the dynamics from the original
system but it's not a spot on match so
let's try to see if we can do better so
notice that the data is kind of looks
like it might be sort of periodically
oscillating so maybe that's a hint that
we should be looking at trigonometric
functions instead of polynomial
functions for library so to do that we
can apply the we can rather than pass it
rather than using the default library of
polynomials we can use a fourier library
which is a built-in method this is just
going to be a set of sine and cosine
functions with different frequencies so
we pass that in in the feature library
attribute and then I'm also passing in
some feature names that's just going to
make the printed version of the
equations involve X and Y's rather than
X knots and x ones so if we fit that new
model we get something that looks like
this
so the first that the derivative of X
looks like a nice simple function of Y
the derivative of Y looks kind it looks
pretty complicated let's go ahead and
simulate out in time and see how they
perform how the model did so it's even
worse than before
in this case the one thing to note is
that the second equation has a bunch of
terms in it which indicates that either
potentially the threshold we set was too
low allowing lots of non informative
terms into the model or it could be the
case that we aren't using an expressive
enough library so we're not able to
capture the dynamics so what we'll do to
get around that is we will use a
different increase the threshold to
eliminate some of those noisier terms
and also set the fit intercept
parameter to be true what that's going
to do is allow constant functions into
the library so to do that we're going to
specify those parameters in the
optimizer and then pass in both the new
the fourier library and this new
optimizer and then still the feature
names if we do all that the model we get
looks nice and clean so this seems like
maybe a good candidate model if we apply
it to the data simulate out forward in
time we see that yeah the fit is really
good
so this seems like it's probably the
model we want to use or something close
to it so now that I've walked through an
example I just want to mention some
advanced features I didn't have time to
get to today so hi Cindy has another
built-in optimizer sr3 which is a
generalization of the sequential a
threshold of least squares method but
we've also made it very easy to use
third-party sparse regression techniques
as optimizers so check out the examples
for a way the examples on in the
documentation to see how to use lasso or
elastic net from the SK learn package as
optimizers we have extra differentiation
methods built-in for handling noisier
datasets there's more customization
available for forming your library
matrix pison you can also handle
multiple different sets of initial
conditions so if I rather than just
taking one trajectory and feeding it in
if I had say run five experiments and
started the particle at five different
points in space and then evaluated those
forward in time I could pass all those
into pi Cindy and have the Cindy object
use all that information to try to find
an appropriate model pi Cindy can handle
discrete time dynamical systems or Maps
so something like the logistic equation
we also have some extra built in scoring
functions if you want to measure
performance in other ways than just plot
so I'll wrap up with jet by just showing
listing some resources to help get you
started so the code is on github we have
a documentation site we recently put out
a paper on the archive that delves into
more the background around Cindy and
tells you about other things that have
been done in the Cindy area and we also
have the original cindy paper which goes
into more mathematical background behind
cindy i really quickly just want to show
the github page so we've got kind of a
little bit more about how the method
works we've got some installation
instructions all that good stuff the
documentation site has documentation for
the API but also there are lots of
examples of how to apply cindy to
different systems we've gone ahead and
recreated or reproduced all of the
examples from the original cindy paper
as a notebook in the documentation
alright thanks for watching that's it